quand j'ai réfléchi
quatre ans 0,6 père sympa mais du coup
moi aujourd'hui où c'est que
trouve dans mon ouailles et dans ma
recherche
fêtes de tichri et tout ce que j'ai
entendu avant ça me parle un petit peu
cette notion de slasher etc
j'ai un petit peu me poser sur les deux
termes de révolution et temporelle à la
révolution je vais reprendre les termes
de chapeau noir sur la vérité est dite
toute vérité passe par trois phases la
première c'est ridicule c'est dangereux
et enfin c'est une évidence
maintenant j'en prends les mots
d'idrissa berkane quelqu'un qui est un
très bon orateur dit au delà la vérité
toute révolution passe par trois phases
ridicule dangereux une évidence en 1969
par exemple on aurait dit aux ingénieurs
de la nasa
quand on envoyait premier homme sur la
lune que leur smartphone en 2019 aurait
autant de millions de fois plus de
capacité de calcul à sion que tous leurs
ordinateurs et wendie il aurait dû c'est
dangereux si ton totalement ridicule on
n'y croit pas aujourd'hui c'est une
évidence
d'autres exemples assez assez qui nous
par la toussaint c'est coco chanel elle
s'est dit tiens je vais dessiner des
pantalons pour les femmes
en 1800 c'était totalement interdite
pour les femmes de porter des pantalons
dans les années 1900 hélène brion qui
est un ancien nantes a porté un pantalon
l'a fait de la prison pour ça c'était
ridicule
c'était dangereux on l'a mis en prison
aujourd'hui c'est une évidence tous les
exemples de révolution passe par ces
phases là selon l'angle de vision dans
lequel on le regarde et ça je vais
revenir dessus
la notion temporelle le temps le temps
qui courent j'ai passé le temps gagner
du temps perdre du temps juste à temps
le just in time aujourd'hui dans
l'industrie tout le monde parle de
justin time du lean comment arriver à
optimiser et c'est le ton aujourd'hui
ceux-ci une révolution si on regarde la
loi de moore elle dit tous les 18 mois
c'est x 2 pour nouvelles technologies
est-ce qu'on n'ait pas envoyé
aujourd'hui de toutes ces nouvelles
technologies on en viendra après
l'entente par les deux blocs chaîne de
quantum technologies on entend parler
d'intelligence artificielle
finalement c'est pas mal de buzz word
mais là temporellement de plus en plus
on entend ces mots là c'est une
révolution
à voir je ne sais pas pour l'image de
foncine hacker connu c'est le film
interstellar j'aime bien aussi les films
et lui il va dans plusieurs dimensions
finalement par de notion temporelle etc
c'est un très bon film et je vous le
conseille est finalement là je vais
essayer de vous emmener dans différents
espaces temps il ya dix ans en arrière
20 ans en arrière dans cinq ans dans dix
ans dans 20 ans on essaie de voir ce que
ça va donner
puis finalement aujourd'hui dans mon job
au quotidien je regarde un petit peu là
dessus
eh ben je suis allé dans l'espace temps
du futur il ya quelques semaines
exactement il ya un mois et demi je suis
parti aux états unis pour une mission au
nom de la confédération suisse sur le
scouting la recherche des nouvelles
technologies et finalement j'ai
découvert quoi je me suis imaginé des
médecins qui dont 10 ans 20 ans serait
qu'un pape d'implanter des coeurs de
bébés ou des choeurs d'adultes à partir
des cellules souches par impression 3d
cette société elle existe elle se trouve
à chicago
elle s'appelle baïola fort dit
aujourd'hui peuvent prélever des
cellules souches humains et faire
croître des coeurs de bébés
c'était plus facile pour faire croître
et aujourd'hui sont dans les phases
cliniques pour faire l'implantation mais
ils sont fonctionnels ça ça peut
paraître dangereux
peut-être même ridicule de dire mais
c'est pas possible ça sera une évidence
qu'on sera capable d'implanter des
coeurs artificiels produit à partir de
nos cellules sur des imprimantes 3d et
ça c'est mon quotidien depuis maintenant
deux ans où je vis dans toutes ces
nouvelles technologies je vois des
choses complètement folles complètement
ouf
comme disent les jeunes aussi laissé un
peu nous mettre dans la tendance je suis
pas encore s'il veut que ça mais
finalement il ya ce côté là maintenant
rétro feedback 20 ans en arrière
vingt ans en arrière j'étais ado on va
dire 14 15 saisons et puis à cette
époque là je découvrais internet ce qui
peut paraître un peu étonnant mais
l'accès web et ai commencé à venir
téléphone portable fallait encore un
petit peu oublié il ya mon père qui est
là mais du coup c'était interdit
j'écoutais du best of bays na qui
connaissent ou pas kurt cobain et puis
finalement bas la nature elle est un peu
ingrate jeu ressemblait à ça donc du
coup merci aussi le temps de faire aussi
son ouvrage donc la notion temporelle
assez sympa aujourd'hui j'ai deux
enfants
j'ai un enfant de 4 ans et puis une
petite fille qui a 6 ans mon enfant
aujourd'hui quatre ans c'est un digital
natives ça me fait halluciner mais du
coup j'essaie de cacher des applications
comme youtube pour aller et c'est un
dessus il arrive toujours à les trouver
ce gamin il écoute du maître gims il
écoute du soprano
j'ai pas mal de chance ils sont plus à
sa mère donc ça me rassure les ce côté
là mais finalement qui est capable de
dire dans 20 ans à quoi va ressembler
notre monde et je suis assez fan de
futurama
c'est matt groening c'est celui qu'on
connaît très bien pour les simpsons
futurama c'est l'idée de se dire on va
se projeter dans le futur en avoir
futura mal pour l'histoire
ça vient de 1939 36 pardon general
motors avait créé en fait une exhibition
sûr qu'elle sera no future les voitures
etc etc
et du coup il y avait déjà pas mal
d'idées derrière clairement sur ce qu'on
avait à vivre ou pas puis finalement où
j'en suis aujourd'hui qu'on a pu
l'entendre
pendant dix ans les dix dernières années
ça a été vraiment un un foehn un
accélérateur à je suis sortie de l'ep
eiffel où j'ai fait un doctorat ce qui
n'était pas vraiment prévu j'ai public à
publier dans le cher qu'un super
magazine scientifique et puis de là je
me suis lancé dans le domaine de
l'horlogerie et je me suis passionné je
connaissais pas et c'était la passion de
maîtriser le temps une fois de plus le
temps est là et c'était de retouche et
finalement à la fois du passé du côté
ancestrale la montre mécanique mais
aussi le futur avec des nouvelles
technologies et super windham c'est
tombé sur certains de mes produits j'ai
eu droit à une pleine page en dix ans le
petit génie de l'horlogerie prédit lin
chance artificielle prédit la robotique
la kobo tic pour aussi le milieu
horloger faire une offre
super j'atteins quelque chose qui est
sympa un artisan york times ok cool mais
là je me suis posé la question dit
finalement fred est ce que c'est ça que
tu veux est ce que tu veux continuer à
travailler dans l'horlogerie depuis que
huit à neuf ans tu travailles dedans
puis finalement tu travailles pour qui
pour 1% la population et encore ce % de
la population c'est des gens wick ont
les moyens de se payer des montres
mécaniques
c'était beau produit mais est ce que
finalement moi il était là est ce que
mon but de se dire tout ce que j'ai pu
engranger comme expertise expérience et
finalement de manière temporelle tout ce
que j'ai vécu dans cette début de vie on
va dire est-ce que c'est là où je veux
aller
et finalement j'ai dit non je dis stop
j'ai démissionné même par un mois et
demi après new york times j'ai dit ok
c'est cool
j'ai fait mes preuves c'est super mais
j'ai plus envie de ça puis là je me suis
trouvé dans un sentiment de dire faut je
trouve la lumière le phare vers où je
dois aller
malheureusement ce que je suis rendu
compte c'est que je vais approcher d'un
phare et j'envoyais des centaines
d'autres autour de moi complètement
esseulé perdu et qu'est ce que je
voulais faire je me suis dis bah tiens
la technologie ou un simplet et puis
l'industrie ça me plaît aussi
et là je suis allé voir la promotion
économique genevoise qu'on appelle la
genève internationale parce qu'ils sont
très avec un melon comme ça sur genève
mais le grand genève qui prend 1,26 dons
ça va encore et du coup j'ai pris la
direction d'une fondation qui s'appelle
l'office de la promotion des industries
technologies et l'idée c'est
d'accompagner les entreprises dans cette
transition digital et numérique pour pas
laisser entre guillemets crever les
entreprises sur le plan de la route
parce qu'elles n'ont pas pu acheter
cette transition digital qui est énorme
c'est un raz-de-marée
aujourd'hui on parle de ligne on
entendra sûrement parlé tout à l'heure
je crois mais ces nouvelles technologies
ils ont clairement un impact sur la
manière de produire et surtout sur la
manière de répondre à des changements de
paradigme aujourd'hui on vit dans
énormément de changement de paradigme et
surtout aussi dans l'industrie sur la
paire nisy la personnalisation sur la
pression sur les prix et ses
technologies là sont très utiles et donc
du coup pendant quasiment deux ans j'ai
pu vivre à travers ses technologies et
ses les amener au niveau des industriels
et là j'ai trouvé un début de mumbai
c'est que finalement on m'a dit mais
fret expert en quoi et aujourd'hui je
suis expert en rien juste un générateur
d'écosystèmes j'essaye de mettre les
bonnes personnes autour de la table pour
qu'elles puissent créer et travailler
ensemble à mener des experts qui sont
académique de la recherche à mener des
experts qui sont de l'industrie des
start up et bien entendu aussi des
jeunes comme vous comme nous qui sont là
pour amener finalement si leurs envies
et d'apprendre et d'acquérir et surtout
d'apporter et ça c'est clairement le
côté de l'intelligence collective
pierre moment je vois les entrepreneurs
puis on commence alors parler de ça de
la blood chaîne de leur parler de la
réalité augmentée l'intense artificiers
du machine learning diplôme une
robotique qu'aux boutiques
aujourd'hui c'est le quantum computing
qu'on entend de plus en plus parler vous
allez voir d'ici 10 20 ans ce sera
quelque chose qui sera tout à fait
naturel et lahi les impacts qui compte
on parle de ça un entrepreneur je me
suis rendu compte que oui c'est clair
quelqu'un qui a à son entreprise depuis
50 ans l'entente c'est à lundi mais
commencent à impacter sont complètement
esseulé déboussolés et l'a de nouveau je
me suis reposé une question sur mon
voyage je travaille dans un système
elle agirait pas plus loin ce que c'est
pas du tout le but mais dans un système
très politique puisque en fait ma
fondation est financée par l'état de
genève
et là je vous dis je crois que je vais
tout planté et du coup j'ai démissionné
à quelques semaines j'ai tout quitté
sans rien donc aujourd'hui je sais pas
je suis au chômage
je deviens ce fameux slasher donc je
donne des cours à lâcher à l'épée fl je
m'occupe de coacher des start up pour
ino suisse qui est l'organisme
fait helvétique fédéral suisse qui
accompagne les entreprises dans le
montage de projets d'innovation pour
récolter plusieurs centaines voire
millions de francs suisses sur des
thématiques assez variés et en plus de
ça je prends du temps pour moi ce qui
m'est jamais arrivé j'ai découvert
j'avais des enfants d'un fait un peu
bizarre vers la et du coup aujourd'hui
je suis posée et je regarde ça c'est
comme si j'étais assis au bord de cette
falaise et je regarde en face de moi et
je réfléchis un peu tout ça puis je me
dis mais tiens si je reprends un petit
peu mais cours que j'ai peut-être plus
avoir ici y en avoir un accent je ne
vois là c'est un peu rude mais je suis
français à la base un ca problèmes de
couple comme quoi ça le temps a fait
aussi son ouvrage
on parle aussi de la courbe de gauss 100
ans ont tous parlé la médiane puis saint
sigma ii sigma 3 sigma qui final je me
dis ceux qui sont là au bout finalement
ces fameux pourcentage qui sont être
l'exception la probabilité les fameuses
oublier les maladies orphelines et c'est
finalement ça qu'on a toujours concentré
dire on a les huiles et les 80's à dire
80 ou 90 % puis ceux qui sont sur le
côté finalement en fait aujourd'hui si
cela c'est les fameux 1%
si vous entendez il ya les night in any
one cent ont dit aujourd'hui 6 1% au
niveau mondial qui décide pour les 99%
99%
du coup c'est peut-être là qu'il faut
aller chercher pis ces technologies
elles peuvent aider aussi aller dans
cette direction là d'aller chercher les
oublier puis avait aussi de se faire
entendre
aujourd'hui la technologie permet oui
d'avancé sur pas mal de choses et permet
aussi de donner la parole à ceux qui
n'avaient pas la parole avant et d'avoir
des solutions
alors pour aller dans ce sens là je vais
prendre quelques exemples juste de se
dire passé présent futur l'éveil des
consciences puis voir vers quoi on va au
niveau de ces révolutions au niveau du
temps j'ai parlé de la médecine alors ce
que j'aime bien dire aujourd'hui c'est
que la tendance de la révolution 4.0
c'est qu'on passe d'un système
complètement centralisé à décentraliser
on explose les codes aujourd'hui à plus
de frontières la blocs chaîne juste pour
un point terme c'est qu'aujourd'hui
c'est au lieu de faire quelque chose
centralisée on décentralise ont fait des
blogs d'informations qui sont répartis
un peu partout dans cloud saas encore un
autre sujet mais finalement et ces
notions décentralise les centres de
production chasse est convaincu c'est ce
qu'on a de plus en plus on aura plus
comme on a eu et qu'on a encore
aujourd'hui des sons de production figé
j'ai un son de production qui à
annecy-le-vieux non demain on va
reprocher les sons de production des
centres de consommation dus à la
personnalisation du aux nouvelles
technologies telles que l'impression 3d
duo claude manufacturing et du à
l'interopérabilité des systèmes etc et
la médecine
elle fait aussi clairement un bond
énorme en ce moment il ya 10 ans 20 ans
30 ans en arrière
le médecin il a fait ses études et
c'était la référence on allait chez
médecins et c'est lui qui disait vous
avez telle pathologie c'est tel
médicament
et voilà là totalement aujourd'hui à
quesnoy technologie on décentralise
l'intelligence artificielle vous avez
qu'à des applications aujourd'hui qui
fonctionne très bien
frondeuse exemple sur le cancer de la
peau aujourd'hui on peut prendre des
images finalement des grains de beauté
on arrive à savoir si un risque
cancérigène ou pas pourquoi parce que
toutes les bases de données des images
et cetera le machine learning
on arrive à éduquer à savoir quels sont
les risques même chose pour la
radiographie aujourd'hui on peut
utiliser l'un science artificiel pour
détecter certains types de radio un fils
chose comme ça l'autre exemple que je
vais donner qui fait un peu mal et là ya
ce côté ridicule dangereux une évidence
d'ailleurs il ya quelques semaines quand
j'ai démissionné m'a dit c'est ridicule
tue démissionner on m'a dit assez
dangereux tu as plus de jobs sur faire
comment jeudi c'est mon évidence et ça
c'est important la fin de se dire on a
tous notre évidence on doit réfléchir là
dessus et l'intense artificiel
aujourd'hui on sait que dans la mode la
maladie du côlon du pancréas on a des
algorithmes qui permettent de bien mieux
déceler ces maladies là pour ça que
c'est souvent médecin qui fait ces
analyses qui regardent etc
c'est qu'il ya des médecins qui met les
pieds au mur parce qu'ils ont peur de ça
dit c'est dangereux en train de perdre
du pouvoir
c'est psychologique et le futur ça va
être quoi
aujourd'hui vous savez que pour 69 euros
vous êtes capable d'avoir votre génome
ou donné et aujourd'hui on voit et eu
pas mal de reportages là dessus des
frères des soeurs qui se découvre
finalement on arrive à faire des matches
mais qui n'a pu se dire tiens y'a
tondent d'infos là dessus et c'est le
quantum technologies va aider aussi là
dessus la puissance de calcul à sion qui
va pousser derrière aujourd'hui pour
analyser un génome ça prend un certain
temps on demain pour annie des analyses
et des millions de génomes grâce au
quantum technologies
ce sera quelques secondes pour analyser
ça l'automobile la mobilité regardez
aujourd'hui je prends mon père qu'elle a
dronneau c'était le truc pour la famille
dreyer gonzalez dont j'ai eu droit la
renault 5 la renault 4l lareau 19
renault 21 la laguna à la vel satis
aujourd'hui c'est la clio ils sont à la
retraite donc du coup c'est un peu mais
aujourd'hui ce qu'on voit sur la sur la
mobilité c'est le partage partage des
ressources partage aujourd'hui encore
plus demain on sera plus propriétaire
notre véhicule
on va commander un véhicule à sera
autonome elle sera devant chez nous on
paye ton on voit aujourd'hui la notion
dubé risation clairement et puis demain
bahia ces fameux drones est clairement
les premiers drones qui vont voler par
exemple la jeunesse ça sera en 2035
pourquoi je dis ça parce que dans mon
ancien job que j'ai quitté il ya
quelques semaines on a monté un projet
européen sur les drones taxi transport
dom par drones et là on est cette ville
européenne abe des grands donneurs
d'ordre derrière il ya du volo kopter il
ya des grands ont des grands instituts
et que cet arrêt de recherche aussi mais
l'idée ce qu'on a dit on veut aller
trail sur 6 1%
on veut les sortir pourquoi parce que
c'est clair que les drones taxi comme ça
les premiers corps ont accès ce sera
probalement les gens qui ont l'argent au
pays pour sa part contre moi qui n'aura
sûrement pas les moyens qui sait si j'ai
un accident faut savoir que quand on a
un accident montagne ou peu importe des
fois l'accessibilité à l'endroit est
compliquée les hélicoptères peuvent y
aller mais ces conditions sont très
mauvaises
très compliqué aussi un drone ça passe
partout on peut sauver des vies
on peut bien entendu elle est beaucoup
plus rapidement sur les suites accidenté
et ramener les personnes là ça touche
vraiment le 99% 99% qu'on parlait tout à
l'heure et de ne pas travailler sur ce 1
% oui bien sûr hubert travail sur les
drones
bien entendu porsche travaille aussi sur
les drones ils ont communiqué a pas très
longtemps mais c'est pas pour les 99%
c'est pour ces fameux 1% et ça c'est
hyper important quand on a monté le
projet sur les drones de dire drones
ambulances pour les accidentés un des
derniers exemples que je veux prendre
c'est l'éducation
et là il ya vraiment destruction sur
l'éducation j'ai pas dire c'est comme
les médecins ce qui a des profits si on
à son agrégation c'est super on peut
être preuve le découvre aussi de mon
côté j'ai fait mes études c'est moi le
puits science entre guillemets
aujourd'hui de manière centralisée on
décentralise qu'est ce qu'on entend de
plus en plus c'est les mook les
formations en ligne aujourd'hui on peut
suivre des cours de gym haïti on peut
suivre des cours de l'épée fait l'on
peut suivre des cours des différentes
unis etc
on donne l'accessibilité à tout le monde
de pouvoir s'éduquer de pouvoir après
de pouvoir se nourrir et on n'est plus
dans cette notion peut dire j'ai fait
mes études car on se nourrit au
quotidien on le voit très bien
aujourd'hui les entreprises l'ont
compris aujourd'hui ce qui met en place
les entreprises c'est ce qu'on appelle
les micros formation donc en suisse on a
monté aussi un projet pour un très grand
groupe de luxe et des groupes aussi
énergétique
tous les collaborateurs tous les matins
ont entre 15 20 minutes de formation en
ligne sur des thématiques intéressantes
aussi pour eux puis la question de
demain puis là c'est un peu pointu
ouvert je suis en train de me dire que
le plus grand formateur mondiale sera
sûrement google et pourquoi pas ce que
google il en train de fonctionner et
c'est pas le seul ces données et
finalement ce qu'on disait tout à
l'heure et on peut prendre n'importe
quel exemple dans la génomique
oui on a notre génome on a aujourd'hui
plein appareils sur notre notre coq
c'est acquis mesure notre qualité de vie
qu'est ce qu'on fait et c'est ces
informations là elles sont vitales pour
nous parce que finalement de manière
prescriptive vous voir prédictive
on pourra anticiper certaines maladies
on pourra aussi anticipé de manière
assez agile quelles sont les formations
les plus adaptées aujourd'hui pour vous
étudiants par rapport aux besoins de
l'industrie demain des produits de
services etc
mais ces informations là elles sont
aussi personnelle et finalement ce que
je mettre en avant c'est que il ya une
étude très sérieuse qui a été menée là
dessus par rapport à cette notion de
donner ses données personnelles et la
première chose on dit va finalement vous
allumer des cierges
on verra ce qui se passe c'est ridicule
deuxième option et ça je le vois chez
les très jeunes avec qui je discute 10
mais moi j'ai rien à cacher mes infos je
peux les données cambridge analytica
c'est un sacré sujet comment faire
passer un président des états unis non
pas en train sur des états mais
carrément sur des petites villes et de
pouvoir retourner la tête entre
guillemets certaines personnes cette
notion de donner les clés facebook ont
dû s'expliquer là dessus et ça
finalement c'est dangereux
je peux faire la politique de l'autruche
et finalement le message d'aujourd'hui
c'est ce que je disais c'est notre
vérité ma vérité vos vérités saisir faut
aller dans l'action pour réfléchir à ça
il faut agir de manière on a de chances
collective je suis pas du tout il a en
train de revendicatif en disant là il y
en ait danger non les techno elles sont
au top mais aussi certaines déviations
sur lesquels on doit être conscient que
nous aussi on est acteur on sait ces
fameux 99% où on a le droit aussi dire
notre mot et pour moi c'est hyper
important et mon loyer là dessus
aujourd'hui
c'est que j'aide aussi pro bono des
entrepreneurs ou des personnes qui sont
un peu perdus par rapport à tout simple
il leur dire attention oui à des dons
j'ai par contre ya des super opportunité
et sans peut travailler ensemble dessus
donc le message aujourd'hui toute
révolution oui toute vérité à ces trois
phases ridicule dangereux une évidence
réfléchissez à votre évidence et agissez
par rapport à ça voilà
[Applaudissements]